ce lundi le marché de louhans prend ses
aises dans une version xxl les usagers
trouvent une configuration différente
par rapport au lundi de pentecôte
traditionnellement très fréquentées et
avec le demande mais il était plus serré
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont des données de
les ans en mettant les plus de place et
c'est pas plus mal parce qu'on circule
bien c'est vrai que c'est vrai que lundi
dernier c'était vraiment gentil avec les
mesures sanitaires du moment c'est
compliqué on a hésité à venir lundi
dernier parce qu'en général le lundi de
pentecôte il ya beaucoup on a attendu ce
lundi 20 pour réunir de nouvelles
mesures de sécurité imposées aux
commerçants comme le port du masque
obligatoire et plus d espace entre les
stands des mesures accueilli plutôt
favorablement chez les exposants n'ont
rien au monde
après il avait promis en place de
dispositifs comme ils ont fait ce matin
que je trouve que ce matin c'est
beaucoup plus fluide et c'est quelque
chose qu'il aurait dû faire l'arrêt du
confinement
d'autres commerçants estiment que le
marché marque le pas il constate que les
clients sont moins nombreux il a tué le
marché a plus personne à regarder
d'habitude à cette heure-là il y avait
beaucoup de monde
hélas beaucoup de monde ça veut dire et
après plus de monde que ça mais
aujourd'hui beaucoup de monde
franchement
les gens ils ont eu peur je prends la
machine mais très dur a relancé le lundi
de pentecôte c'est normal ça a bien
marché et après ensemble les gens
achètent des leurs courses alimentaires
ça s'arrête là du côté de la mairie il a
fallu prendre les choses en main pour
imposer le port du masque les
commerçants sur le marché ont
l'obligation ailleurs dans d'autres
commerces n'est pas forcément
obligatoire on a vu pendant la période
de confinement que ce n'était pas du
tout le cas dans les grandes surfaces et
avec le maire on a beaucoup alerté le
préfet à ce sujet ce qui nous étonne
c'est qu'effectivement ça serait plus
simple pour nous à gérer si l'état avait
un discours clair la municipalité
souhaite imposer les mêmes mesures de
sécurité jusqu'au 14 juillet au moins
avec la bonne volonté de tous les
commerçants